Want some pizza? We all love the good pizza pie to talk to, but it turns out there's a simple scientific solution to double your pizza experience!
Everything depends on the area of ​​the circuit
That equation you may have heard in your youth, where the area is equal to a square squared, where the radius represents the radius
If we add some numbers, you may notice something interesting
For example, since we measure pizza in Anchorage in North America,
The 8-inch pizza area is about 50 square inches
Simply take the radius of the pizza, if it is 4 inches in this case, put it in the equation and here it is!
But if we do the same thing with a 16-inch pizza,
Which has a larger diameter twice, we find that although it is obvious it may seem twice as large, but actually has more than 200 square inches!
It means pizza more than 4 times!
This is because the area of ​​the circle increases with the radius box.
However, the price difference between an 8-inch and 16-inch pizza is often not even as low as the price
Let alone multiply it four times.
In fact, the NPA conducted a study on more than 74,000 pizza prices in America
An interactive chart was created to determine exactly how pizza prices change with size
How much is the amount of pizza you get when you require a large volume.
For example, a 20-inch pizza has more space than a 14-inch pizza sandwich or six 8-inch pizza sandwiches
They are an average of $ 9 cheaper than buying two 14-inch sandwiches and cheaper than $ 30 for six 6-inch sandwiches
This is the pizza equation.
The more pizza you have, the more money you keep in your pockets
But why is the pizza very delicious from the ground up? We have revealed the scientific secret behind the fact that pizza is the ideal food on ASAP thought
While we prepare delicious recipes. Check out the video if your tongue can hold it. And subscribe to more weekly videos.